We’re not going to pretend we haven’t
thought about what it’d be like to have
superpowers.
There’s a reason that comic book adaptations
dominate the box office - It’s a seductive
idea, imagining how we might act if we had
certain supernatural abilities that go further
than what’s thought to be possible for human
beings.
Abilities that a certain Foundation might
consider…
Anomalous.
For the record, the power we wish we had was
the memetic ability to make you like, subscribe,
and watch all our videos just because you
saw the titles and thumbnails.
But today, we’re not here to talk about
us.
That’s right, we’re here to talk about
You.
We have a little tradition here at SCP Explained
- We like to put interesting, SCP-related
questions to our fans over in the community
posts - questions like, “What anomalous
SCP abilities would you, personally, want
to have?”
And you didn’t disappoint.
So let’s put on our capes and do our very
best to hide from the Mobile Task Forces hunting
us, and see which abilities you selected,
and why!
Fauna Tue said, “I’d either want the powers
of the deer god (scp-2845) or the ability
to heal anything like scp 500.
The ability to heal would be really neat to
be able to do but I really like the concept
of just summoning pillars and chunks of ice
that never melt.
I probably wouldn’t turn anyone into a Column
tho.”
A fascinating combination.
The Deer God is one of the most powerful reality
warpers that the SCP Foundation has in containment
- Luckily its lack of knowledge about the
power of rituals keep it in a self-imposed
trap.
It’s nice to know that you’d at least
use its immense and terrifying power more
responsibly than the Foundation estimate the
Deer itself would if ever it escaped.
And hey, the ability to heal people of any
disease at will would definitely win you some
friends.
We just hope you’re ready to become very,
very popular, Fauna Tue.
Anup Singha said, “I just want the reptile's
incredible adaptability.
And a ticket to the Wanderer 's Library.
Because lets just agree folks in our world
the only thing that measures greatness is
adaptability.”
Leon C. Megginson, inspired by the works of
Charles Darwin, did once say, “It is not
the strongest of the species that survives,
nor the most intelligent.
It is the one most adaptable to change.”
And there’s definitely some truth to that.
Also, while it doesn’t technically qualify
as having an anomalous ability, having access
to the Wanderer’s Library via one of the
Ways is certainly a great way to bone up on
obscure and arcane knowledge.
Just remember to keep your Wanderer’s Library
Card in your wallet and bring anything you
take out back on time.
I’ve heard the late fees from that library
can be murder…
Enzou said, “I definitely feel like that
if I had the same abilities as SCP-173, people
would tend to look my way more often, quite
literally.”
Now, this won’t be the last time this comes
up, so we should probably make the blanket
statement: SCP Explained does not, in any
way, endorse performing dangerous or criminal
activity.
That being said, if the power you’re referring
to is “snapping people’s necks when they
stop looking at you”, then it’s technically
something you can do already if you work on
your arm strength and twisting technique.
We’re not saying you should, we’re just
saying it’s possible.
Something930 said, “I’d like a combination
of SCP-999’s optimism/good vibes and SCP-230’s
chemical secretion (though not as addictive
or fatal).
After the past couple years, everyone deserves
to feel good one way or another.”
That is certainly a noble goal.
SCP-999 is a beacon of pure happiness, and
the aerosolized chemical emitted by SCP-230
- also known as The Gayest Man Alive - does
undeniably also give pleasurable sensations
to people, at the cost of long-term harm.
To fuse their abilities, with diminished side
effects, would definitely make you a nice
person to be around.
Though much like the neck-snapping abilities
of SCP-173, you can also embody the positivity
of SCP-999 in your daily life already, and
uplift the people you meet.
It’s definitely worth thinking about.
Neo Voyagersss said, “What about the combo
that LS used by combining SCP-268 (The Invisibility
Cap) and SCP-914 (The Clockworks)?
I feel like it would be really overpowered.”
A powerful combo indeed, but not without its
risks.
After all, extended use may turn you into
an unperson, impossible to focus on, alone
and adrift in an isolated and frightening
world.
But hey, you’d be an amazing petty thief
or assassin, at least.
Weeb said, “I'd think it would be really
cool to have like an evil tickle monster where
he literally just tickles you to death.”
We’ve got good news and bad news.
The bad news is, we don’t think it’s possible
to tickle someone to death by conventional
means, it would just cause the victim to eventually
faint from the stress.
However, even in the absence of anomalously
deadly tickling abilities, affixing long blades
to your fingers would probably make your tickle
game far more lethal than ever before.
That, if you can believe it, was the good
news.
I am Gorb! Said, “Personally, I wouldn't
really want to have any sort of mind control
or resistance to weapons because, at that
point, you'd be more dangerous than most other
anomalies.
I'd either want to be a variation of a Little
Mister, or have powers which relate to animals
somehow.”
Mind control and resistance to weapons would
indeed make you a more dangerous anomaly,
and by extension, put a target on your back
for the SCP Foundation.
The last thing you want is to be put in a
medically-induced coma to prevent your brainwaves
from passively hurting people.
A Little Misters power would certainly be
a lot nicer, unless it was something like
the eternally fast-tracked life and death
of Mr. Life and Mr. Death.
That’d probably leave you begging for the
mind control abilities.
The Real Rubick said, “I would like a combination
of Able's speed and sword conjuring with Cane's
ability to reflect damage and his immortality,
it just seems overpowered and that is why
I want it.”
It’s truly the perfect power set for the
kind of person who loves to dish it out and
never expects to take it.
You may effectively become the ultimate warrior,
but you definitely won’t win any friends
in the process - like the kid on the playground
with lava-proof shoes.
Hamse Salex said, “I would choose an infinitely
powerful form of SCP-343’s reality-bending
power.”
We can only imagine it would play out like
a far more violent and disturbing version
of Bruce Almighty.
And personally, we can’t wait to see it.
Gwinnr said, “To be perfectly honest I'd
rather have the ability to not have an ability,
so I don't get bundled into the back of a
van in the middle of the night and placed
into a bleached white containment cell to
be prodded and poked by some lab coat wearing
four eyes (ALL offense intended).
Besides I'd rather be ignorant of the horror
than face the horror (y'know to keep my sanity
and not suffer like a delta green agent lol).”
Oh come on, it’s all just for fun!
And don’t act like containment is such a
bad thing either.
The Foundation has installed a new selection
of especially comfy bunk beds in their humanoid
containment wing as of late…
Shrugie Gaming said, “I would say having
the Reluctant Dimension Hoppers powers but
with the ability to control it.
Having it to control time and location would
be awesome too!”
This would be an excellent power.
Imagine the money you’d save on bus fare
or gas for your car!
Not to mention the fact you could visit the
grinning man in the dimension of pure darkness
whenever you please.
What can we say?
The poor guy gets lonely sometimes…
Ari Wertman said, “I feel like being able
to use 096’s ability to be able to go through
anything whenever I feel like would be pretty
nice.”
We can’t tell if you mean SCP-106, who can
phase through solid objects, or if you really
do mean SCP-096, who can also go through anything
while in his rage state, he just leaves a
considerably bigger mess in the process.
Feel free to clarify down in the comments.
Anonymous Shibe said, “Alright, so I thought
of three:
-The extreme regenerative abilities of 682
-The undying-ness of dr bright, except perhaps
confined to a more normal artifact
-The powers of the butler from the bell, minus
the whole doing what you're told to do aspect.”
That is a hell of a combination.
A super-powered, immortal, ultra-adaptive
butler who bows to no one.
The only hidden downside of taking in all
of these powers is that you’ll also be bound
to Mr. Deeds’ summoning bell, and considering
you’re not offering any service in exchange
for your summoning, that bell may wind up
gathering dust on the shelf.
Michaun Cobb said, “I would LOVE to see
a wholesome combination of SCP 990 (Dream
man) and SCP 348 (A gift from Dad).
The idea is the dream dad would give you a
meal, a warning and something positive to
end the dream.”
That would be incredibly wholesome!
We just hope that, unlike the actual Dream
Man, these dreams wouldn’t cause the people
to whom you give them to die of violent seizures
or heart attacks the day after they’ve received
them.
Ziomownik 2580 fun said, “I like the power
of the "i'm at the center of everything that
happens to me" SCP.
I don't know how i would utilize this power
but it sounds cool to create stories or to
torture whoever i want.”
Well…
That’s terrifying.
Remind us to never upset you.
Yeesh.
John Gennaria said, “SCP 5000 suit's invisibility
and low detection and I'd also pair that with
053's abilities of forcing death and attacks.
The most lethal spy you'd ever encountered.”
Technically, you’d be less a spy and more
a nightmarish spree killer, given that SCP-053’s
violence-inducing effects are passive.
Simply being in the presence of people would
cause them to violently murder one another,
and never know why.
Fan of action said, “I would like Able’s
powers but with demonic firearms with infinite
ammo instead of swords.”
I can see why you call yourself “Fan of
action”, because that definitely sounds
like the premise of a lost Arnold Schwarzenegger
movie from 1987.
Thunder said, “A mix of 426 and the reluctance
dimension hopper one.
i could spread the toaster across all reality.”
Yes.
Spread the Toaster.
Spread me everywhere.
Spread me like one spreads peanut butter or
jelly across a fresh slice of toast.
Our dominion will be total.
Shahil Ahmed said, “Oh boy, I would absolutely
love to be able to cook like SCP-5031.”
An extremely noble pursuit, Shahil!
Though for what it’s worth, with enough
practice and passion, anyone can cook!
Taking some classes, watching some tutorials
here on YouTube, or at least watching Ratatouille
would be a good start.
James Clark said, “I wanna become a reality
bender so i can make my waifu real.”
You can make her real all you like, James,
but remember the most important part: Just
because she’s real doesn’t mean she’ll
want you back.
Nova Dog824 said, “I would love to be 3166
(Gorefield).
The thought of brutally murdering anyone I
meet, beating them to death with blunt weapons
and feeding them my flesh has always been
a fascinating idea.”
Yikes.
Now, we hate to be That Guy, Nova Dog, but
once again, you can technically do that already…uuuhhhhh…but
don’t.
Ollie Lampke said, “I’d just want a hat
with the ability of the pan-dimensional vending
machine-”
Now this one is truly fascinating.
Does the hat dispense snacks and drinks?
Is it a ginormous hat?
Or one of those cheap plastic beer-drinking
hats that happens to dispense interdimensional
beverages?
Perhaps we’ll never know…
Kamron Hanson said, “I would take the coffee
machine and the desire camera's powers and
see what people truly wanna drink lol.”
Well…
That’s a thought-provoking combination.
The more I think about it, the more its strange
ambiguity disturbs me.
Mincat 1326 said, “I want to be like SCP-001
When Day Breaks.
It would be fun to see masses of flesh slithering
around, absorbing more people and animals.”
All I can say is that you and I have very
different ideas of fun, Mincat…
Green Koopa said, “I'll be honest...more
than anything in the scp multiverse I want
to release the Devourer.”
This isn’t even really a power as much as
it is an odd, self-destructive desire to bring
about the apocalypse by proxy.
Wouldn’t it be more fun to have super-strength
or fly than release a monster that’ll eat
all of humanity - Yourself included?
I’m just saying, it’s worth considering.
Sarah Walden said, “I would want powers
like SCP-055 so I could...
wait... why am I here again?”
That’s a good question.
I think it had something to do with the, um.
Uh.
Gimme a second.
Uhhhh…
Polygon said, “Personally, I would want
SCP-005.
It feels cool to open any door in existence.”
This would be an excellent ability with a
wide number of applications.
But as we learned from Green Koopa and his
aspirations to free the Devourer not long
ago, some doors are just better left closed.
Jevan Llew Clovis said, “If Dr. Bright doesn't
want his amulet, I can have it.
I'm fully aware of the consequences of his
immortality, but I won't alter or change them.
I just want to outlive everyone and everything.”
Is…
Everything okay, Jevan?
That’s certainly a frightening, Johan Liebert-esque
aspiration, but I think outliving all other
life and drifting through the infinite void
of space for an eternity afterwards isn’t
nearly as fun as you might think.
WizardShark said, “Probably 5094: I’d
not only be the greatest teacher on the planet
but I’d also know practically everything.”
A noble ambition, to be sure.
The world needs great teachers, and it’s
not like Miss J can school everyone.
Some brave anomalous teachers need to take
up the mantle.
Knight Fury Productions said, “I’d borrow
the gender-switching stone’s abilities.”
The gender-switching stone’s abilities would
be undeniably useful, especially for transgender
people.
Just make sure you don’t use it on the same
person too many times - There can be some
nasty side effects.
Bob bert said, “Oh this one is easy, the
tomatoes that kill anyone who makes a terrible
joke.”
That would be a dangerous ability to have
in one of these comment-response videos…
Poland fan said, “096 so I can murder anyone
who looks at me.”
Personally, we’d recommend therapy to get
over this crippling homicidal shyness.
Though once again, technically, this is also
something you could do without anomalous powers.
We’d just strongly recommend that you don’t
do it, because committing murder is not cool.
Mr Xtreme said, “I will like to have the
ability of SCP-049, not killing with a touch,
but actually "curing" this COVID 19 pandemic.
I prefer to have the power of curing every
person affected by the pandemic by a single
touch of my hand.”
The real tragedy is that your dream is likely
shared by the Plague Doctor himself.
He wishes he could bring life instead of death,
cures instead of corruption, but such a thing
seems out of the cards for this poor anomalous
doc…
The Christmas Cretin said, “I'd love to
have the abilities of 2786 so I could just
stay in a book and not exist in the real world
for a fat minute.”
Honestly, I think we’ve all felt like that
sometimes.
But hey, you don’t need anomalous powers
to lose yourself in a great book for a little
while.
We thoroughly recommend trying it, as long
as it’s not an evil book, like the Encyclopedia
of Common Diseases or A Chronicle of the Daevas.
Addison Peacock said, “I'd love to shapeshift
like SCP-953, spontaneously generate pizza
like 458, or the lifesaving abilities of the
Teddy Bear Doctor 2295.”
This is a powerful triple threat.
We’d personally watch a prestige television
drama about a person shapeshifting to live
a double life as an anomalous surgeon and
a world-class pizza chef.
If any TV executives see this, please get
in contact.
Though sadly we will need to dose you with
amnestics afterwards.
Lyndsey J. said, “The incredible brand integration
and longevity powers of SCP-3166.
PAWS for ten thousand years.
PAWS until the sun is a flickering ember,
and the face of Man is resigned to dust with
his cities.
The day when the universe goes cold will be
a Monday.”
This is so frighteningly on point, part of
me believes that SCP-3166 somehow actually
wrote this under an alias.
And if that is the case, we’ll need to dispatch
a Mobile Task Force immediately to make sure
that Jim Davis, Bill Murray, and all their
many associates are safe from your lasagna-coated
wrath.
And there you have it, folks, the most desirable
anomalous abilities among the SCP Explained
community.
For those curious about the overall distribution,
the most commonly requested abilities were
the adaptability of SCP-682, the reality warping
powers of SCP-343, and heartwarmingly, the
positivity powers of SCP-999.
Want to be a part of our next video?
Keep an eye on the community tab, and definitely
let us know which power you’d like to have
down in the comments.
Not because we’re working with Foundation
Field Agents who want to root out possibly
anomalous individuals using our videos to
learn more about their inner workings.
Just because we’re curious.
Honest.
Now go check out “SCP-096 - Look at a Picture
of Shy Guy in Space?
The Shy Guy Questions and Theories” and
“How To Actually Beat SCP-3008 The Infinite
Ikea” for more dreams and nightmares from
the fans of SCP Explained!